[Music]
welcome to Tech news briefing it's
Monday May 15th I'm Zoe Thomas for The
Wall Street Journal
apple is taking a different approach to
launching its latest device we'll hear
from our Apple reporter Aaron Tilley
about why the company is taking a rare
risk with its new mixed reality headset
but first Twitter is getting a new boss
Elon Musk has chosen a new CEO for the
platform advertising executive Linda
yaccarino
in a tweet musk said she will take over
in about six weeks musk who became CEO
when he bought Twitter for 44 billion
dollars in October said last year he
planned to hand over the Reigns to a new
CEO but for a company that's already
gone through a lot of transformation in
a short period what does this mean
with me now to discuss it is Twitter
reporter Alexa course Alexa can you
start by telling us who Linda yaccarino
is and what do we know about her
background yeah yakur you know what
comes from a previous role as chairman
of global advertising and Partnerships
at NBC Universal she was with nbcu for
more than a decade and I think the real
takeaway is that she is known in the
advertising world she has a lot of
experience in advertising how does her
background fit with musk's vision for
what Twitter is going to be or for what
he wants Twitter to become Twitter has
typically gotten most of its Revenue in
nearly 90 from advertising so
advertising is just such a key role and
that seems to be what industry Watchers
are taking away from this announcement
is that this seems to be a way to
improve how Twitter 2.0 is doing with
advertising work on those relationships
with advertisers which as we know has
been a struggle since musk took over and
can you remind us how advertising has
been doing since he took over it's been
tough a lot of advertisers had concerns
about how musk might approach content
moderation they had concerns about the
New Direction and Leadership of the
company and many of them paused spending
on Twitter some say they've come back
others say they still have stayed off
Twitter and the big question here is
what can Twitter do to fix that going
forward all right once she takes over
what is musk's role turned into musk
said he is still going to be involved in
Twitter he said he will transition to an
executive chairman and CTO role and
he'll still be responsible for
overseeing product Software System
operations but the way musk put it
Friday morning is that yakarina will
focus primarily on business operations
while he focuses on product design and
Technology after
ocarino and ask interacted all in the
past yeah actually last month she
conducted an on-stage interview with
musk at a conference in Miami Beach
during that interview she pressed him on
some issues she asked about his
sometimes controversial tweets but she
also struck some positive notes and I
actually have a quote here that I wrote
down that stood out to me where she said
quote if freedom of speech as he says is
the Bedrock of this country I'm not sure
there's anyone in this room who could
disagree with that so what does that
tell us about their potential
relationship managing Twitter together
that's a big question right it seems
like the strategy is that she can focus
on business operations advertising while
musk can focus on technology but
certainly there are going to be
questions like content moderation
policies freedom of speech that fall on
leaders of a social media platform
alright that was our Twitter reporter
Alexa course
apple is known for its standout devices
the iPod iPhone and Apple watch have
historically dominated their product
sectors now apple is getting ready to
unveil one of its most experimental and
unconventional products in its history a
headset that combines a virtual and
augmented realities the device which is
expected to debut at its annual software
Conference in June is set to break a lot
of norms for how the company releases
products our Apple reporter Aaron Tilley
is with us to explain so Aaron you've
spoken to people familiar with this
project can you start by describing what
we can expect the headset to look like
yeah so it's going to be a like a pair
of goggles sort of like ski goggles
wrapped around your head there's going
to be an attachment with a external
battery pack that will sit on your hip
and it's going to be
like essentially a VR device where it's
completely encloses you in this virtual
world but on top of that there's going
to be a lot of cameras sitting out front
of the device that can show you the
world around it and give you a ability
to see the world around you and overlay
all this sort of virtual world stuff on
top what makes this product different
from products that Apple has launched in
the past yeah so I think really what
marks this is different for apple is
they're coming into a new category that
is still extremely unproven in the past
they've really entered into markets that
are quite a lot more well established
you know apple has a history of coming
into categories and really making them
um you saw that with digital media
players with the iPod smartphones with
iPhone wearables with the Apple watch so
certainly Apple says track record of
really making the market but in entering
into this space whatever you want to
call it the metaverse mixed reality
augmented virtual reality it's just so
early in this space
um and apple really needs to get going
much earlier than I think they would
have in the past from a product design
perspective a headset was never going to
look like an iPhone but is there
anything that's different in the way way
Apple has approached this headset as
opposed to other products it's released
in the past certainly design wise it's
going to not be as Sleek as other Apple
products the external battery pack will
I think add to a certain amount of
clunkiness in terms of design and we've
seen other headsets of this type kind of
launch with these separate packs like
for example the magic leap has a a pack
that sits on your waist that has the
computer chips and the battery but for
Apple you'd expect maybe a more
contained and Sleek appearance and
design and on top of that apple is
entering this Market without a lot of
expectation in terms of demand yeah
let's talk about that for a second
because other companies that make
headsets and are in the virtual reality
space they've been struggling to build a
robust Market here so why does Apple
want to get into this space there are a
lot of people saying it is the next big
stage for or technology how people
experience technology and how they will
experience the world in the future and
so I think everybody's sort of
experimenting and if you're an important
player in consumer electronics like
obviously apple is you have to be trying
these things out and you have to have
some stake in this what did industry
analysts that you spoke to say Apple's
chances are of finding out in this
market I think because it's Apple
everybody's expecting something pretty
impressive maybe it's not the end-all
be-all of what we expect from this kind
of Technology but it's certainly going
to sit above many others some people are
certainly skeptical of the product and
really it's placed in the market I think
there is plenty of skepticism whether or
not Apple really even needs to do this a
former director in their marketing
department Michael gardenberg said that
he doesn't really see this as an Apple
product given the sort of limited appeal
it'll have why is Apple's CEO Tim Cook
take taking this risk and does he have
anything to lose if Apple doesn't make a
Big Splash in headsets I think they've
spent enough money on it and enough time
that to not launch anything and
certainly I've heard this from people
that would be a mistake it's been many
years since Apple's entered into a major
new category last time was nearly a
decade ago at the Apple watch and it's
time for that company to keep releasing
new products it can't just keep relying
on the iPhone forever so when do we
expect this product to be released and
for people who might want it how much is
it going to cost so far it appears based
on conversations with folks that their
plan is to announce it in June at their
developers conference and just as a
caveat there they could always delay it
and the price tag is looking around
three thousand dollars so quite a lot of
money alright that was our reporter
Aaron Tilley and that's it for today's
Tech news briefing if you want to find
out more about any of the stories we've
covered head over to our website
wsj.com you'll find a lot more Tech news
there
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
[Music]